from ryan gosling and sandra bullock to
justin timberlake and jenna dwan tatum
et's running down seven celebrity
couples we totally forgot dated
this is like a whole it's a whole thing
you know
um not that long we were like friends
friends that then dated jenna dwan tatum
revealed to andy cohen in may she dated
justin timberlake for a hot minute yeah
it's crazy what's even crazier nicole
kidman was once engaged to lenny kravitz
i try to embrace all parts of my life
and get this steel and tyra banks the
pair dated in the 90s before the kiss
from a rose singer married heidi klum
and even way before heidi and tyra
starred on america's got talent she's
very real she's a lot of fun then
there's ryan gosling and sandra bullock
who dated in the early 2000s after
co-starring and murder by numbers he's
17 years her junior now you're making me
nervous
another ryan reynolds that is dated
singer alanis morissette
many years before linking up with lena
dunham jack antonoff once had a fling
with scarlett johansson
we all know john mayer had a flash in
the pan relationship with taylor swift
but does everyone remember he also dated
jennifer aniston for a little over a
year he even accompanied her to the 2009
vanity fair oscars afterparty
and let us not forget ashton kutcher and
january jones's relationship the pair
dated in the 90s well before their mega
fame and fortune
where did you get that like i don't even
know
[Music]
you